c'est une marée humaine comme on en
avait pas vu depuis 2019 en Chine après
trois ans de mesure sanitaires strictes
les Chinois retournent fêter dans leur
famille
le nouvel an lunaire redevient la plus
grande migration humaine du monde
cet homme rentre dans sa région natale
pour la première fois depuis 2020
celui-ci non plus n'a pas vu sa famille
en trois ans il sert à ses parents dans
ses bras et il leur donnera des petites
surprises à manger
plus de 2 milliards de voyage devraient
être enregistrés pendant cette période
en Chine au moment où le pays fait face
à une vague sans précédent de cas de
covid en raison de la levée soudaine des
mesures sanitaires le mois dernier
voire triplés dans les urgences de
certains hôpitaux de Shanghai et de
Pékin l'arrivée dans les régions rurales
de Chine des déserts médicaux dans
plusieurs cas risque d'aggraver la
situation
un point tel que le Président si Jinping
a exprimé ses inquiétudes dans une
adresse à la Nation
nous sommes si heureux de pouvoir
voyager et de voir que les restrictions
ont été levées 17 femmes beaucoup de
Chinois veulent oublier l'angoisse de la
covid ici à Taïwan c'est aussi le retour
des foules après 3 ans de restriction
chaque jour à taper des milliers de
personnes visites ce marché du nouvel an
lunaire en plein air dans un quartier
historique les autres activités
traditionnelles associées à la fête sont
aussi très populaires
nous quittons l'année du tigre qui a été
très difficile nous espérons que l'année
du Lapin sera remplie de joie Taïwan a
levé presque toutes ses mesures
sanitaires dans les derniers mois ici
Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada Taipei